like I never understand when guys got  girls and they step up but they don't  just step up well they actually have  like they start taking girls on dates  and stuff I'm like bro what are you  that's what I was saying earlier like if  it's Madness  how do you have enough energy to be  dealing with that but the reason they do  this is because like their home lives  are [ __ ] boring and they're growing  up boring and women is looking after  their kids no but yeah but you're boring  they're going to meet a girl and she's  exciting right if he starts financially  funding her says you know I'm gonna pay  for you your studies yo he's cheating in  a different way